you guys and talk about fight oh yeah
well I I thought that the wait would you
watch the Donda zone eyewash ball yeah
what really how much do you pay a month
for dissolve I don't know but I I
already paid it a while back when he had
this first fight on digital has for sure
I had to get yeah yet the app yes
where'd you go where'd you get that bet
oh my could TV my smart TV you
downloaded it all and they say I didn't
do it I didn't my wife he had someone do
it yeah okay but fancy if you illegally
no I didn't know cuz I want to watch on
the big screen but if you did yeah
sometimes I asked her on the big screen
I don't say camara when I could have
find out how to hit you up uh-huh cuz
you've been do it for years
all right stop winking at me everybody
can see it you're not being subtle dude
hiding your mouth working cut it out I
do but if all right okay would you turn
hard not to drop a name his wife was
pregnant he interviewed I mean he
answered Susie goes this is my wife and
she's pregnant he goes hey stop winking
at me it's not an accomplishment what do
you think of I think Canelo's I got in
canelo
I belongs in conversation with that one
of the great fighters put him I put him
in I believe if you took Canelo and you
put him up against Marvin Hagler Sugar
Ray Leonard you put him up against
anybody in history I think he holds his
gaze right there I think he holds us I
don't know what's next for him I think
he's not mentally sound Danny Jacobs is
such a [ __ ] beast a lot of people
think he beat triple G I do and that's
how good he is and bigger and Canelo is
just so fundamentally sound as whatever
isn't it I just don't know where Canelo
goes from here not a whole lot of like
does not a major fight Earl Spencer jr.
talk to you'd go up and fight him which
would be amazing fight yet amazed he's
so much bigger than Spence
he's my arm spans but Spence's I don't
know I did like there's like the triple
G the the rubber fight I guess I'm not
crazy about that
for at 54 no no that was a 60 yeah yeah
I yeah that's big that's big jump for Oh
Spence that's a big jump for Earl spam
but for Cannella there's like no
blockbuster fighting a think of right
now for like trip the triple G Danny
Jacobs was gonna be a lot to us and when
you look at the way he was punching
Canelo was blocking almost all of the
shot his head movement was oh god no so
good did you know what he's my favorite
to watch he also changed his style up oh
he's so nice t stop fighting the way it
was in the beginning and start chaining
and he was sitting there moving forwards
thing about can I can do both yes I mean
on outside of box he can do that what
you do against dribble jeah you want
apply pressure you can do that what she
did in the second fight against Tribble
Jimmy you want to do a combination of
both you can do that Danny Jacob alone
he's so fun believable Danny there's
nothing like after the fight there's
nothing yeah I don't know man there's
nothing really like oh I have to see
this next now right
that's just tricky who is there is there
anybody Earl spends the only thing but I
think Earl spends we're all Spencer's
gonna go up from 47 or also go to 54 or
whatever oral Spence fight and Shawn
Porter net yeah I know I may be to
Crawford is nice a fine he's fine Shawn
Porter thing yeah Crawford in here not
fighting no Spencer that's the night I
want to know Porter in confidence I want
to see that fight but I wonder how
Cannella does can I was online can all I
think walks at 180 it's thick he's very
thick but he could fight at 54
oh yeah they could meet at 54 yeah
there's just no like huge fight for him
where you're like oh this is the mat
like for Spence and Crawford like that's
it for Mikey Garcia like there's remote
engkau it's like oh we can do this like
you can think of fights for them but
otherwise now I don't know cowboy
Cerrone continues to astonish
yeah you look great man [ __ ] gopher
you get that connor fight in July you
think that's gonna happen
I think if if there's a fighter who can
bring Conor out it'd be Donald Cerrone
they mate Jax checks all boxes for both
guys this place could Donald up to third
I think maybe what's this do cuz I
planta was fourth I could to his fourth
or depends his room and he was fighting
at 70 when he left he's right to at 55
jump to 70 ya lost there one there
now he's back 55 eight now so number
four I think they I think they need to
put him somewhere yeah I think yeah I
think you at least got up on that four
if not three I'd love to see him fight
Tony Ferguson I'd like to see him fight
me too Tony for his needs fight for
title I [ __ ] him over yeah give him a
tunnel I agree but I would only fight to
make you have cowboy on call for Dustin
Poirier could be if someone gets hurt
yeah be steps up shot yeah but outside
that Cowboys should go Connor necks in
July then fight the winner of Dustin
Poirier could be I think the cowboy
rides off in the [ __ ] sunset with
this cute little son and his wife
this one goes make more babies love them
there's the game I love well I I feel
like I feel like the the person that
gives khabib the biggest fits in that
entire division is actually Donald
Cerrone because his wrestling is so good
his wrestling's better his wrestling and
jiu-jitsu is arguably maybe better than
all of those guys including Tony first
absolutely never not absolutely not
absolutely not so time for some
wrestling college yeah and it's
phenomenal rest like darl boys not da
boys good wrestler
no we're happier now wrestled though
when does he won with last time he's out
wrestle he was out punched by Darren
telling stuff but I haven't seen him out
wrestled right I mean name name of rest
of that he's fought well he's a DI I've
heard from guys who've trained with him
you probably know that I'm telling right
now not but not a better grappler
wrestler and Tony Ferguson not a better
grade silly as good no no where near
really the wrestler
there's a person's background shut like
Saint when first as good as this but
we're talking my MMA we're talking about
as a matter
I don't can hang wrestling with anybody
I could beat well that's their way off
her could be was different yeah so you
think Tony's gets more challenge hold
he's getting taken down by could be yeah
yes
Cowboys getting taken down Michael yes
it's everybody's game I could be is can
you get back up weather the storm right
and drag him out to a fourth who does
that better Tony over 100% as far as
scrambling yeah Oh Tony all day
Tony's a scrambler that's what he does
yeah catch you in the scramble
Tony verse khabib is the best matchup to
make it 155 Bar None hands down outside
that there's really no one [ __ ] with
could be
there's no one cuz you might handle you
can't get nine close that that that one
thing that Connor did where he doubled
up on the on the one hand whether is up
standing up or on the ground that did
keep khabib at least at bay for from
facing but he's go on top of you
sabi doesn't matter that's still winning
like you're be not gonna but he's not
gonna blow anyone out the water as far
as knocking him out or no it's that one
formula it nobody can solve he's gonna
take you down it's that here free
everyone that you know he's gonna scoop
your legs you can't do anything about
everyone the world's get taken down it's
just Tony's the best kind of scramble
guy in the game so Tony could do that
just engage you can wrestles the ass off
problem with just engages though he only
has one speed you know his first gear
and he even says I guess that's just
when it was funny when he was talking to
you on your I watched a clip of your
drug yeah and he was very sensitive
about sort of being called an exciting
fighter which could no reckless fine no
he his trigger for him is a great
conversation his trigger for him is when
he called my reckless fighter that's
right me he says all's calculated yeah
which I don't quite agree with but I
don't know but I don't know we had I
don't know why I didn't watch the
episode I don't they show a lot me and
get into it but not like where where are
you I have a point of view I was like
well no dude you're you're reckless in
this regard yeah and he's a cab it's all
Cathy that's fine but that style is
reckless and I went obviously you can
upset understand and bad would be a
trigger that would be if you tell me I'm
shitty at something and I know I'm not
yeah that didn't trigger me yeah it's
not see something touchy for me he's a
guy who fight you in a phone booth and
and and go toe-to-toe and I think that
can always be considered with small
clubs more reckless than a guy who's
more care especially with his wrestling
but that's why it's so excited but him
versus kebede that opening round be fun
now as it's two three four if could be
where ever taken out she remember
Justin's on Friday no rest I didn't know
you what's his wrestling Paul American
you know no shadows Christ on all of
American I'm stunned
wow wow and but his striking is burn the
curbs he's more explosive but after the
first round if you thing down with what
happens there's like somebody tell me he
was gonna he was a really good wrestler
then he wanted to go wrestle at
University of
I think it was in John Ehret ASU and and
I and I said he goes I just couldn't
hang and I go why goes see you so you
know those guys in high school that are
undefeated they wrestle all three years
nobody beats him he goes everybody on
the team is like that at ASU yeah like
an 81 program they're all like yeah
they're all he's like they were all so
sick it was like yeah it was it was like
I was like they were so he was they were
so good I couldn't imagine meeting them
anytime and you're not gonna get it
looked at unless you're like top 1% year
state so [ __ ] retired and this is and
then you get these guys in the FSA just
different well thank you a guy like
could be world class I don't know who's
gonna beat him myself
30 times while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift it's a gift
you